balding um
huh all right never mind
wait can you repeat it
i mean no i i feel like because
i'm balding like i don't have hair so i
feel like it would be weird for me to
say
no to someone else for balding
physically
uh it's not like it's something that i'm
drawn to
it's not something i'm gonna count
against a person
i have dated someone who had like a
widow's peak
balding situation um and i thought it
was unique and interesting
i mean it depends i think cause some
people wear bald really well
i have a huge crush on stanley tucci it
depends on the stage
and what stage are you balding like have
we already been dating for
a few years like are we married like
what's happening
i'm not gonna cancel somebody out just
because they're balding
[Music]
if you're balding and you're just
letting some hairs grow really long and
then put them over
like think donald trump or something
like that that would probably be like
yeah deal breaker
but if you just are shaped like you
don't have hair
that's fine with me i like a lot of hair
i like to like run my fingers through
their hair so if they had hair
maybe like yeah it would be more
attractive to me
but again it's about the person
[Music]
if it's a deal breaker for you you know
do you
but i think it's gonna be as we get
older increasingly harder to find
men who aren't bald it's more important
just like your connection with the
person
you cannot judge people based off of
things like that leave all the sexy bald
men to me
as long as you're confident and you rock
it then you're probably gonna get laid
[Music]